السلام عليكم ورحمه الله يوم اندلعت
ثورتهم قبل اكثر من ست سنوات صد السوريون
مالنا غيرك يا الله واليوم ودول الخليج
العربيه تعيش ما تعيشه من ازمه وانقسام من
المؤكد ان ذلك الهتاف يزداد قوه وهم
يهمسون به وتلهج به السنتهم في جوف ليل
عربي بهيم فقد شكلت دول الخليج على مدى
السنوات الماضيه ضمن قوى اقليميه عده سندا
مهما للثوره السوريه وسدا في وجه المتكال
بين عليها من دول وميليشيات سعى النظام
جاهدا ان يمكن لها في سوريا فما تدعيه
ازمه الخليج على ثوره الشعب السوري وهل
يتاثر النازحون والمهاجرون السوريون من
ديارهم جراء مشكلات البيت الخليجي نتابع
تقرير الزميل فتحي اسماعيل ثم نبدا
النقاش لا يعرف النطاق الذي قد تمتد عليه
الهزات الارتداديه للزلزال السياسي في
الخليج العربي هذه الايام غير ان الازمه
السوريه تبدو في مهب تلك التطورات بلا شك
واذا كان من الارجح ان تنزل الازمه بردا
وسلاما على نظام الاسد وحلفائه فمن المؤكد
ان الشعب السوري سيدفع جانبا من فاتوره
هذا الشرخ الخليجي وبصرف النظر عن موقف
قوى المعارضه السوريه من الازمه الحاليه
فالواضح ان خساره الثوره ستكون على قدر ما
كانت استفادتها سابقا من كيان خليجي بدا
موحدا ومتناغم في تعاطيه مع الملف السوري
صحيح ان دور الرافعه الخليجيه لم يصل حد
حسم المعركه ضد النظام غير انه في المقابل
حال دون نجاح ذلك النظام وحلفائه في الحسم
ايضا وهكذا استمرت قضيه الشعب السوري
وتطلعاته في الحريه حيه متفاعله في
المحافل الدوليه كثير من المكاسب السياسيه
التي حققتها المعارضه السوريه تعزى الى
الكتله الخلجيه سواء باقناع عموم العرب
وجامعاتهم في عزل النظام السوري وطرده من
الجامعه ومؤسساتها او حتى في المحافل
الامميه عندما دعمت تلك الاطراف قوى
المعارضه في المفاوضات من جنيف الى استانا
او في اروقه الامم المتحده وفي مجلس الامن
تحديدا عندما عملت دول الخليج مجتمعه على
محاصره النظام السوري دبلوماسي
وفرض عقوبات عليه وحلفائه فضلا عن محاولات
التصدي دائما للفيتو الروسي لا يستثنى من
ذلك الدعم العسكري للفصائل السوريه
المقاتله على الارض وقبل ذلك وبعده الجهود
الاغاثه الهائله التي فرضتها الازمه
انسانيا على خلفيه تحول ملايين السوريين
الى نازحين ولاجئين في الداخل وبلدان
الجوار تضطلع قطر بدور محوري في العمل
الانساني فهي بهيئات الحكوميه وجمعياتها
الخيريه من يزود السوريين بالخيام والطعام
والدواء والماء بالتنسيق مع منظمات
الاغاثه الدوليه في معظم الاحيان ومما زاد
الطين بالله ان قرار بلدان خليجيه
الاستعاضه عن القضيه السوريه وغيرها من
ازمات المنطقه بحمله لاستهداف قطر حمل
متغيرات ربما لم تخطر على بال تك البلدان
واهمها اعلان تركيا القوه الكبرى في
المنطقه ذات الدور المفصلي في الازمه
السوريه انحيازها الى الدوحه في هذه
الهجمه المريبه وغير
المسبوقه لطالما ردد وزير الخارجيه
السعودي عادل الجبير خلال العامين
الماضيين القول ان على بشار الاسد الرحيل
سلما او حربا دون ان يحدث ذلك طبعا في
اوجي تماسك الموقف الخليجي وت
مع الرؤيه التركيه فهل ينزاح الاسد الان
بعد هذه الواقعه وخلط الاوراق والمعادلات
بل قل هل تستمر الرياض ومن معها في مجرد
قول ذلك ناهيك ربما عن ان تكون الجماعه من
هنا فصاعدا معنيه اصلا بقضيه الشعب
السوري نناقش هذه القضيه مع ضيفنا منظ
الدكتور محمد قواص الكاتب والباحث السياسي
ومع ضيفنا من غازي عنتاب حمزه العبد الله
المدير التنفيذي في الهيئه العالميه
للاغاثه والتنميه نرحب بضيفي الكريمين
دكتور محمد قواص هل من اضرار سياسيه
وميدانيه ظاهره الان على الثوره
السوريه نتيجه هذه الازمه
الخارجيه ظاهره حتى الان لا لكن ستظهر
طبعا الرافعه الخليجيه التي تحدثتم عنها
في التقرير هي اساسيه في هذا الصراع
الداخلي السوري والموقف الخ كان منسجما
تماما في دعم هذه المعارضه من خلال تواصلي
مع بعض الشخصيات المعارضه هناك حرج كبير
داخل هذه المعارضه وهناك ايضا عدم وضوح
مستقبل الافاق السياسيه لهذه المعارضه لكن
ايضا يجب الاعتراف انه في الاونه الاخيره
كان هناك من بعد ما اقيمت عمليه استانا
وبعد ذلك استانه عسكريا وجنيف سياسيا كان
واضح ج جدا ان هناك نوع من الاحتكار
للموضوع السوري يتعلق بالولايات المتحده
روسيا وايضا ايران وتركيا بمعنى او باخر
وكانه المجموعه الخارجيه كانت مواكبه لهذه
الهمه الدبلوماسيه واعتقد انك انه كان
هناك ثقل دبلوماسي اما من اجل وقف اطلاق
النار او من اجل اطلاق عمليه سياسيه ناجحه
اليوم واضح جدا ان سوريا تعاني المعارضه
السوريه تعاني من هذا من هذا من هذه
الازمه داخل
مجلس التعاون الخليجي وانه بامكان هذا
الخلاف الداخلي ان يتداعى بشكل سلبي على
مستقبل التسويه
السوريه س يتداعى لكن الاضرار ما زالت لم
تظهر لحد الان كما قلت وهنا سؤال للاستاذ
حمزه العبد الله اذا كانت الاضرار
السياسيه ربما قد تحتاج وقت طويل لكي تظهر
تجلياتها ما هي الاضرار على الاقل في
الجانب الاغاثي والانساني التي لمستم وها
منذ بدايه الازمه الخليجيه في
الميدان بالطبع ال المنظمات الانسانيه
الخليجيه اي كانت الجزء الفاعل في اغاثه
النازحين الذي سواء داخل سوريا او في دول
الجوار الذين تجاوز عددهم ما يقارب 13
مليون شخص بحاجه لمساعدات انسانيه حسب
تقديرات الامم المتحده
اي الدور الخليجي كان واضح منذ البدايه
سواء
بالاطار الاغاثه العاجله او اطار التعافي
المبكر وهذا بطبيعه الحال سيظهر خلال
الفتره القادمه
ب الفجوه الكبيره التي
ستظهر جراء التضييق على المؤسسات الفاعله
سواء في قطر او في غيرها بلوائح الارهاب
وغيرها
وهذا خلط للاوراق غير مقبول من طرفنا
كمنظمات
انسانيه الاطار الانساني هو تحده منظومه
من الاتفاقيات
والقانون الانساني الدولي وغيرها من
القوانين التي تعزله بشكل كبير عن الاطار
السياسي ليبقى باطار الحياد خلط الاوراق
بهذه الطريقه هو تحصيل لمكاسب سياسيه جراء
من من جراء العمل الانساني وهذا مرفوض
بطبيعه الحال ام وهذا ينصب بطبيعه الحال
على المستفيد والانسان
بش المحصله
وهذا
يعني الفعل الذي س سيفاقم معاناه النازحين
ومعاناه اللاجئين داخل سوريا وفي دول
الجوار والذين هم يتطلعون الى مواقف
انسانيه واضحه تخفف من معاناتهم لا لا
تفاقمها ولا تزيد منها دكتور محمد خواص ا
السعوديه طالما كانت تردد على لسان وزير
خارجيتها بان على الاسد الرحيل وسواء ذلك
كان ذلك سلما او حربا يعني تذكر هذه
التعبيرات التي كانت تستخدم وكان التحالف
الخليجي التركي هو السند لهذا الموقف الان
في ظل هذه الازمه وهذا المستجد الخليجي هل
تعتقد ان هذا الموقف
سيتا موضوعيا سيثرون
الازمه الخليجيه الداخليه وضعت اولويات
بيتيه محليه واعتقد ان الاجندات الاقليميه
تتراجع شيئا فشيئا سواء المتعلقه بالموقف
الخليجي او الموقف القطري حتى دعونا نكون
واضحين ومباشرين لكن ايضا من يستفيد من
هذا من هذه الازمه هو النظام السوري
والاجندات ايضا نرى انها تتقدم على الارض
العسكريا باشكال مختلفه طبعا ايضا ما
يتداعى على الارض هو مجموعه من المواجهات
التي حصلت بين فصائل المعارضه طبعا حتى
الان هذه المواجهات ليس لها علاقه مباشره
بالخلاف الداخلي في مجلس التعاون الخليجي
لكن يخشى وهذا طبعا كلام بالمعارضه ان
تتاثر هذه المعارضات التي كانت تتلقى دعما
واضحا سياسي واكثر من سياسي من دول الخليج
بهذا الخلاف الداخلي طبعا موقف المعارضه
حاليا اضعف المرجعيات الخليجيه مشغوله ب
باولويه
اخرى طبعا ايضا يضاف الى ذلك الموقف
التركي الذي ايضا اصبح محدودا اذا ما قرنا
بالهمه الروسيه اساسا وبالهم الامريكيه في
هذا الشان فاعتقد ان هناك احراج سياسي
احراج عسكري احراج التخطيط ايضا لدى هذه
المعارضه عمليا كيف سيكون تاثير السياسي
في يعني تمظهراته تجلياته كيف
ستكون يعني اولا المرجعيات حاليه نحن في
دعمنا للمعارضه السوريه كنا نبحث كنا كانت
هذه المعارضه تعمل ضمن مرجعيه اقليميه
ومرجع دوليه هذه المرجعيه الاقليميه حاليا
غائبه او مشغوله او لديها اولويات اخرى
فالمعرض السوريه في مقاربتها سواء في
المفاوضات المباشره مع النظام او سواء في
مقاربتها للمنظومات الدوليه والاقليميه
التي تتشكل هي تفتقد هذا الانسجام الخليجي
الداخلي وبالتالي يتاثر طبعا الموقف سوري
الذي سيبحث ويمكن ان نقول انه
سيرتجف اي موقفه بانتظار الوصول الى الى
صيغه لحل معين ا في في منطقه
الخليج استاذ حمزه ع عبد الله بعد صدور
قائمه القائمه قائمه اشخاص وال الكيانات
الصادره عن محور القطيعه والمتهمين
بالارهاب والتي ضمت اهم الجمعيات الخيريه
القطيه القطريه التي يشهد لها يعني
بمساهمات وباعها الكبير في العمل الاغاثي
ودورها في في سوريا بالتحديد ودعم
اللاجئين سواء في في في لبنان او في في
تركيا او في في الاردن الان هذه اللائحه
هل سيكون لها تاثير عملي على ارض الواقع
في عمل هذه الجمعيات علما بان هذه اللائحه
ليس ليست لم تعتمد
دوليا لائحه باول ردات فعل الامم المتحده
رفضتها
وفعليا دول المنطقه سترفض هي لائحه اعتمدت
على تصنيف سياسي اكثر من اعتمادها على اي
اطار انساني اخر اي
ولكن التصرفات وال ردات الفعل هذه يعني
تنذر بخطر على العمل الانساني طبعا
التجارب ال او التجربه الانسانيه القطريه
التي ت امتد لاكثر من 30 سنه من فعل الخير
والعمل الانساني بالمنطقه هي تمتلك من
الحصانه من خلال صفات الاستشاريه بمنظومات
الامم المتحده والشراكه مع وكالات الامم
المتحده والمنظمات
الدوليه ما يحصن ولكن تبقى بالاخير العمل
الانساني وذري الارهاب هاجس لدى كثيرين من
المساهمه خصوصا عند المتبرعين والجهات
متبرعه هاجس خطيرين باتجاه الاقدام
والمساهمه بالعمل الانساني اي
طبعا ادراج جهات بهذا الوزن
وبهذا الثقل في لوائح الارهاب هو تعد سفر
ب على العمل الانساني وهو خلط ومحاوله
لحصول على مكاسب سياسيه من جراء وصم
مؤسسات بالعمل الانساني انا سالت سالت هنا
سالت استاذ حمزه سالت عن عن تاثر العمل
الاغاثي
ب هذه
التصنيفات بطبيعه الحال هو سيتابر ولكن
ليس الاثر الذي يراد به من خلال الجهات
التي ادرجت هذه المؤسسات على ارهاب ف كما
ذكرت ان ردات الفعل الاوليه سواء من امم
متح
المفات والام المتحده ذرت انها لا تعتمد
التصنيفات التي تاتي من الخارج
وا اشادت بالجهود القطريه لذلك هي قد تؤثر
ولكن
على قدر محدود نعم دكتور محمد قواص قلت
قبل قليل بان المستفيد الاول من هذه
الازمه هو النظام السوري هو
ايران دعم الفصائل في الميدان فصائل ال
السوريه المقاتله الى اي حد قد يتاثر
وبالتالي قد يكون له ذلك ايه ايه ايه قد
يستفيد من ذلك النظام ويحقق من ذلك مكاسب
وكيف يبدو مستقبل المعارضه السوريه
السياسيه يعني المعارضه السوريه المستقبله
هو هو سوري محلي هذه المعارضه قامت بهذه
الثوره لاسباب سوريه وليس لاسباب اقليميه
اتى الد الخليجي بعد ذلك مناصرا لكن هذا
لن يغير شيء في طبيعه ان هذه المعارضه
ستبقى معارضه ما سيتغير ان هذه المعارضه
ستكون مضطربه ستنتظر هذا هذه التسويه
الخليجيه او هذا الحل الخليجي بفارغ الصبر
لاحظ معي ايضا اليوم استمعت الى مصادر
روسيه في التعليق على زياره وزير الخارجيه
القطري الى روسيا روسيا القلق الاساسي من
هذه الازمه هو سوري هي طبعا تحتكر بشكل او
باخر الحلول السوريه سواء كانت في استانا
او حتى في في جنيف وتعتبر ان العنوان
الخليجي اساسي لهذا الحل وبالتالي ايضا
فصائل المعارضه وهي فصائل اساسيه في اي حل
مقبل حسب النظريه او حسب المقاربه الروسيه
تحتاج لهذه المرجعيه الروسيه انا طبعا
تواصلت مع بعض يعني شخصيات معارضه هي فعلا
محرجه وهي فعلا مضطربه وتنتظر ايضا وتراقب
وتتامل طبعا هذه الازمه لما لها من
تداعيات مباشره على مستقبل هذه المعارضه
وعلى مستقبل السور دتور دكتور في المقابل
دكتور هل تعتقد بان الاسد الان اتسعت
امامه الفرص لتعزيز وضعه في مواجهه
المعارضه
السوريه يعني اعتقد انه كان هناك خصم كبير
اقليمي هذا الخصم حاليا مشلول لاسبابه
الخاصه النظام السوري يعتبر انه
يمتلك يعني هامش اوسع وهو يتصرف حتى اعليا
وحل وحتى من خلال الصور التي اذيعت مؤخرا
حول اي يعني تجوال بشار الاسد المريح وحول
ايضا الاخبار التي قدمت حول ان القوات
السوريه بدات تقترب من الحدود العراقيه
ويتحدث بصفه وطبعا بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
بعض المصادر الروسيه التي تتحدث عن انتهاء
الحرب السوريه كل ذلك يدور حول هذه الازمه
الخليجيه حول هذا الغياب الخليجي وحول
ايضا غياب عنوان اساسي ل للمعارضه السوريه
يعتقد ان النظام السوري مستفيد جدا من هذه
القوه اشكرك دكتور محمد قواص الكاتب
والباحث السياسي من لندن كما اشكر من غازي
عنتاب حمزه عبد الله الناشط السياسي
السوري والمدير التنفيذي في الهيئه
العالميه للاغاثه
والتنميه الاجراءات التي فرضتها السعوديه
ومن معها ضد قطر لم تتسبب في تداعيات
اقتصاديه وسياسيه فحسب بل ادت الى
انتهاكات واسعه لحقوق الانسان حسب منظمات
حقوقيه بينها العفو الدوليه والمزيد مع
غاد عويس في المحطه الحصاد الثانيه a